-A growing number
of Republicans,
including Congressman
Matt Gates,
are pushing to make Donald Trump
Speaker of the House
if they retake power in 2022.
But aside from that, they're
laser focused on the big issues
facing Americans
Hot Pocket prices
and cream cheese shortages.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Because the Republican Party
remains in the grip
of an authoritarian cult
led by goons,
grifters,
and gnocchi-shaped weirdos
who are intent on staging
a slow motion coup
to dismantle democracy,
there is no serious conservative
movement in this country.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
I forgot to do examples,
I thought that was
shorter than usual.
Because the GOP's focus is
solely on upending democracy,
they have nothing
to say about policy,
which is why ever since the
start of Joe Biden's presidency,
we've been subjected
to one moronic right wing
freak out after another,
like when they told us
Democrats wanted
to come to your house
and take all your hamburgers
and Dr. Seuss books
and then strap you down
and forcibly inject you
with a secret microchip
that teaches you
critical race theory
and electroshocks you
any time you try
to buy a MyPillow online.
And now, here's the new one,
thanks to Joe Biden's radical
left wing agenda, decent,
hard working Americans
can't have cream cheese anymore.
-Did you hear about this?
Some bagel shops
in New York City
are just days away
from running out of cream cheese
amid supply chain shortages.
-A cream cheese shortage is
hitting New York City
bagel shops here from one bagel
seller getting schmeared
by this supply chain crisis.
-Important breakfast time news
there's a schmear shortage here
in New York City
as bagel shops say they're
having trouble
restocking cream cheese thanks
to the supply chain crisis.
This is big news here
in New York that you're running
low on cream cheese.
-Now, I think they only
latched on to this story
for the bagel based pun --
"Small business owners
are getting schmeared
by this shortage,
so locks your doors
or you might get creamed."
Also, I don't think
bagels and cream cheese
is the breakfast
of Fox News viewers.
They can't have all
that gluten and lactose.
Are you trying to kill
all our grandpas?
But the shortage is real.
I asked for my regular
at the deli yesterday,
and the guy said
the best he could do
is lox and almond butter.
And then the almond butter
was so sticky
the lox stuck
to the roof of my mouth
and I spent half the morning
looking like
I had a second tongue.
Plus, I asked for it
in on everything,
and they gave me this
because in Joe Biden's America,
that's in everything now.
But seriously, though,
is this cream cheese
thing really big news?
I mean, I live in New York City,
so I've heard about it.
But until my cab driver
tells me about it,
I refuse to think
it's a big deal.
And the only headline
I'm hearing from him is,
"any one of us
would have done
what Chris Cuomo
did for his brother."
I should note I only take
New York City cabs in 1974.
I'll believe the cream
cheese shortage is real
the next time
I walk through the park
and someone whispers
"weed, coke, Philly's best?"
Also, can I just point out,
I feel like it's
unnecessarily cruel for you
to keep holding up a bagel
with cream cheese
while there's a guy telling you
about his cream cheese shortage.
Poor bagel shop owner.
You trying to torture the guy?
"Oh, is this what
you're looking for?
This delectable
little confection?
Why we have an entire fridge
full of them downstairs
in a Fox News dungeon.
It's where we put the bolts
in Sean Hannity's neck."
But you know what?
Fine, whatever.
This is the kind
of silly content cable
news channels use
to fill time.
They don't have
our unique ability
to stretch out "Closer Looks"
with totally unnecessary
and perhaps even
counterproductive tangents
where we speculate about
I don't know,
what it might sound like
if, say, I don't know.
Owen Wilson starred in the
movie about a college dropout
who, I don't know, inherits
a bagel shop from his father.
[ As Owen Wilson ] We're out of
cream cheese. Geez, man, wow.
[ Normal voice ] And of course,
in this scenario, his father
would be played by, I don't
know, like maybe Al Pacino.
[ As Al Pacino ]
Alright let's go.
It's time to spread some butter
on some [bleep] pumpernickel.
Yabba-labba-loo.
[ Normal voice ] Whatever.
We've been over using it anyway
to get out of these tangents.
So from now on, I'm just going
to say "Whatever."
Whatever.
The point is,
Fox filled some time
with the dumb segment
about a supposed
cream cheese shortage.
But then the official Twitter
account of the House Republicans
tweeted an image
from the segment with the words
Biden's America.
Alright.
First of all, you're clearly
not from New York,
because if you were,
you know that everything
bad here gets blamed,
not on the president,
but the mayor.
That's the job of being mayor
to soak up all the rage
and resentment in the city
like a charcoal pill,
so we don't all kill
each other in the streets.
And it's a weird time
for New Yorkers right now
because Eric Adams
has been elected,
but it's still de Blasio's lame
duck job for a few more weeks.
So everybody's just waiting.
Poor Adams doesn't realize
what's coming.
Right now people are saying,
"Give em hell, Adams."
And then the second
he's sworn in,
"Where's our [bleep]
cream cheese?!"
The correct way to address
the mayor in New York City
isn't "your honor," it's
freakin'.
As in freakin' de Blasio
let the rats steal our pizza.
True story! De Blasio
hands the "freakin'" title
over at the inauguration.
Whatever.
[ Laughter ]
So Republicans have gone
from trying to scare people
into thinking Joe Biden is
stealing your hamburgers
to thinking Joe Biden
is stealing your cream cheese.
And yet, that is somehow not
the dumbest food based attack
launched
this week by a Republican.
Because Louisiana
Senator John Kennedy,
who despite his exaggerated
corn-pone accent,
went to Oxford
and used to be a Democrat,
predicted this week
that thanks to inflation
and the Democrats
Build Back Better Plan,
the price of one particular
frozen food
is going to skyrocket.
-When I first heard about
the Build Back Better bill,
I thought to myself, "You know,
this is satire, right?"
And then I took a look at it,
and I was amazed
beyond imagination.
I mean, it's breathtaking.
Trillions of dollars
of new spending, new taxes,
new debt,
new welfare programs.
The only way I know how to
improve it is,
is with the shredder.
It's going to fuel inflation.
When a Hot Pocket
costs you $10,
remember,
we're building back better.
-Does Kennedy really think
his voters care
about the cost of Hot Pockets
or is it just the perfect
brand name for his accent?
[ As Kennedy ]
Hot Pockets?
[ Normal voice ] It sounds like
a nickname you get in Louisiana
if you set your pants on fire by
standing too close to a grill.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Kennedy] Looks like
Hot Pockets couldn't
wait for his hot dog.
The fact is, Kennedy just
wouldn't sound as good saying,
[As Kennedy] Totino's Pizza
Rolls or LaCroix.
[ Normal voice ]
Even though LaCroix does sound
like a small town in Louisiana.
[ As Kennedy ]
You have a lot of nerve showing
your face in LaCroix again.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Also,
I just want to point out,
as I have before,
but I do not believe
this man's accent is real.
That's what British actors
sound like
when they try Southern accents
and overdo it.
[ As Hugh Grant ] Yes.
Sorry, Hugh Grant auditioning
for the role of, uh,
Colonel Sanders.
[ Clears throat ] You'll hear my
secret recipe when you pry it
from my cold, dead hands.
I can definitely, definitely,
definitely do better.
Dreadfully sorry.
[ Normal voice ] Whatever.
I don't even think Republicans
really expect people
to fall for this [bleep].
They just have
nothing else to talk about
because they're not a party
that is sincerely interested
in governing.
So they have nothing
to say about policy.
Their only goal is power,
and they're laser focused on
getting ready for the next coup.
After nearly pulling off
the last one.
Yesterday, a group of
Republicans,
including Matt Gaetz,
even went so far as to suggest
that if they win back power
in 2022,
they would spend
most of their time
trying to prove the unhinged
conspiracy theory
that the January 6th
insurrection
was actually staged by the FBI.
Gates added that
they would focus on that
rather than on working with
Democrats to pass legislation.
-We are going to take power
after this next election,
and when we do, it's going to be
the days of Jim Jordan
and Marjorie Taylor Greene
and Dr. Gosar and myself
doing everything to get
the answers to these questions.
-Can you expound a little bit
on what the days of Jim Jordan
and Marjorie Taylor Greene
are going to look like?
-Yeah, we're going
to send subpoenas.
We're going to conduct
real oversight.
We're going to show up
in person and get answers.
The notion that Republicans
are going to take control
of the House
and we're going to hold hands
in the warm spring rain
with the Democrats
and legislate is ludicrous.
-[ Laughs ]
Alright. No one thinks
you're going to legislate.
But what was that about holding
hands in the warm spring rain?
[ Laughter ]
Is that a "Four Seasons" lyric?
Is he in the touring company
of "Jersey Boys"?
Because that
would explain the hair.
[ In falsetto ]
♪ Oh, what a night ♪
♪ We held hands
in the warm spring rain ♪
♪ Then she left me
'cause I was insane ♪
♪ Let's all remember
what a night ♪
Wow, without a warm up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Without a vocal warm up.
Our hair is pretty close.
I'm just realizing it.
[ Laughter ]
As I made the mistake of looking
at the key and I'm like
Glass houses, as they say.
[ Laughter ]
And that was somehow not
the craziest part
of the press conference
with Gaetz also floated
an insane idea that has been
gaining traction on the right
that if Republicans win back
the House in 2022,
they might try
to make Donald Trump Speaker,
which is possible
because technically
the Speaker of the House
does not have to be
a member of Congress.
Several Republicans,
including Trump's
former Chief of Staff
Mark Meadows,
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert,
and now Gaetz
have floated the possibility.
And Gaetz said
he had run the idea
by Trump himself.
-If you do retake the house,
do you want ex-President Trump
to be the Speaker?
-I would.
-Have you
talked to him about it?
-I have.
And that might seem like
a short answer,
but it's probably how much
he talked when he brought
the idea up with Trump
before Trump cut him off.
We want you to be
Speaker of the House.
[ As Trump ]
Speaker of the House?
I have a speaker in my house.
And we call her Alexa.
We love Alexa, don't we folks?
We love, we love Alexa.
All the answers she's got all
th-- You know why we love her?
When you ask her a question,
she answers, you know.
That's why I call her the
reverse Melania.
Not hearing much from Melania
these -- Alexa.
Alexa, why isn't Melania
talking to me?
-Because she hates you.
-[ Normal voice ] Now,
the point is these people's
depravity truly knows no bounds.
Trump let a deadly pandemic
ravage the country,
leading to mass suffering,
he stoked a violent coup
to overturn the election,
and he personally
came into contact
with more than 500 people
after testing positive
for COVID and hiding it.
And yet his sycophants
in the Trump cult
are still willing to do anything
to get him back into power.
Trump could take a dump
on the Constitution,
and they'd say it was
just a little --
-Schmeared.
[ Laughter ]
There's been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver,
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.